in a way and camouflaged these artillery
soldiers are waiting for their orders
they say sometimes it can be a long wait
and at other times it can be very busy
with very short notice to fire but this
unit is unique they have Father and Son
fighting side by side
he is my own blood he said he wanted to
join the Army how could I let him go
alone he has a life to live I am older
and I wanted to serve him side by side
we have been serving for more than a
year we support each other we kind of
got used to it they've not always been
here firing the artillery gun Euro's
life was in the trenches around bahamutu
where he says he came face to face with
fighters from the Wagner group
he says he was surprised by their
tactics with soldiers from Ragnar would
charge at the trenches and scream give
up we look them in the eyes and were
firing he says he still remembers those
scenes vividly
it's much easier to serve with your
father back in civilian life we were
more like Father and Son but here we've
become more like friend since I'm
worried if one of us or both of us die
they received the order to fire
[Applause]
back at the base they monitor using a
drone they managed to strike an
ammunition storage
the biggest threat these positions face
is from Russian drones and we've just
heard there's one overhead so we have to
move really quickly out of this area
inside in the relative safety of the
bunker they get some respite they sleep
side by side here in small quarters with
other men from their company it's basic
but that's life of soldiers on the front
line the counter-offensive is still
taking place
they both expect to be even busier in
the coming weeks and months but yours
love hopes to get his son through it and
get him home to his mother safely
I said
eastern Ukraine